vous visez les entreprises d'abord cette
année parce que vous estimez qu'elles ne
remplissent pas vraiment leur devoir la
en matière de protection de la vie
privée ça malheureusement il ya trop
d'entreprises qui fonctionne au canada
et qui néglige complètement ou
partiellement la loi qui gouvernent les
renseignements personnels parce que
mendy est donc une fois qu'il ya une
plainte enfin enquête on les oblige à
changer leur leurs pratiques
mais je déplore qu'ils aient toujours
autant qui semble faire fi de la loi
maintenant vous dites aussi vous vous
pointez du doigt aussi le gouvernement
vous estimez qu'il pourrait lui imposer
une loi beaucoup plus contraignant pour
les entreprises pour qu'en fait elle
protège les renseignements personnels
dès le départ tout d'agir après la une
fois les pots cassés
absolument je pense le canada traîne le
pied et dans sa protection des
renseignements personnels dans le
secteur privé et le secteur public
dans d'autres pays on voit que les lois
se durcissent qui est plus de il n'y a
plus de possibilité de vraiment prendre
des sanctions assez sévères en cas
d'entorse à la vie privée et donc il ya
plus d'attention de la part des
entreprises à ses lois au canada à peu
près rien n'arrive
et il est toujours la possibilité pour
une entreprise de changer ses pratiques
et donc il n'y a pas d'amendé n'y a pas
de sanctions personnelles etc
je pense ça doit charger cette année
vous nous parlez aussi de facebook vous
avez réussi à obtenir des changements de
la part de ce média social
oui c'est ça encore facebook la grâce et
une plaine qu'on a eu une enquête
les personnes qui sont victimes d'un
un imposteur c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
avait une fausse page là le nom de nom
d'une personne c'est sa bénéficie
maintenant de non seulement facebook va
enlever le faux site mais valdes aider à
aviser tout les gens qui ont reçu des
fausses communication mais en général
100 soit scabreuse ou insultantes et
donc ils peuvent plus rapidement refaire
leur réputation
j'aimerais qu'on fasse un petit bilan
rapide de vos dix années en tant que
commissaire à la vie privée aujourd'hui
bon à ce que je sais pas si vous avez eu
beaucoup de changements mais aujourd'hui
quelle est la plus grande minutes
l'appui dans le hockey est le grande
menace à la vie privée aujourd'hui c'est
mon décompte qui me fait dire minutes où
il menace la plus grande menace je pense
c'est le dépouillement sans examen
minutieux de des nouvelles technologies
et donc on est toujours en mode
rattrapage j'ai parlé du besoin de
changer la loi je pense est urgent parce
que les technologies se déploie
extrêmement rapidement et ans court
toujours après les effets néfastes
est ce qu est ce qui est vraiment moyen
parce qu'on a l'impression que cette
technologie peuvent toujours contourner
la loi ce que vous pensez ce que dans
d'autres pays les plus exemplaires que
nous est ce qu'un moyen vraiment de
faire des lois qui nous protégera mieux
je pense que oui je pense que si la loi
prend toute la question de protection
des renseignements personnels au sérieux
comme dans la loi sur la concurrence
dans d'autres lois qui réglementent les
compagnies envahi prêter plus
d'attention
actuellement les questions de protection
des renseignements personnels sont très
bas dans la liste de choses importantes
pour des compagnies parce qu' à peu près
pas de conséquences significatives
si on ne suit pas la loi mais dirk a pas
de sanction n'est pas suffisamment
sanctions et des pays plus sévère en
terme de sanction c'est ça exactement
or qui on a dans la question de fête où
le mouvement après laffaire
sarbanes-oxley aux états unis toute la
question de réglementation des actions à
la bourse toutes les règles financières
toutes les règles anti concurrence ont
des sanctions beaucoup plus sévères et
donc reçoit beaucoup plus d'attention de
la part des dirigeants de l'entreprise